leur faire payer les riches c'est une
captation les secondes les clôturer ce
sujet les gilet jaune ne fait pas
n'étaient pas ceux qui votaient c'était
c'était une épée de deux corps électoral
choper sur twitter qui n'est pas rien à
voir avec l'opinion fondamentale du
gilet jaune moi je suis chef cheikh
agnès vert devient celle d'association
on est comme handicap ishaq un truc un
gilet jaune qui en a on a des systèmes
de votation ce qui marche très bien mais
il ya quand même plein de sujets qui ont
été nous songeons sabrina si celui ci
est cette catastrophe ne tiens
absolument pas à mon plateau chacun en
fait qu'à sa tête mais tant pis je
persévère c'est la preuve que c'est la
croiser que ce sujet continue à vous
passionner
j'espère pense au temps du permis de
conduire
il ya donc des opérations escargot
organisées par les sociétés d'auto
écoles qui n'ont pas trop envie qu'on
réforme leur business
or il y en a justement qui veut réformer
ce business c'est le président de la
république emmanuel macron il l'a redit
aux jeunes avec lesquels il était en
discussion la semaine dernière à étang
sur arroux
c'est en saône et loire on a commencé on
va renforcer une vraie politique pour
baisser le coût du permis
1 on a rouvert et accélérer le code pour
qu'ils soient obtenus avant les 18 ans
et en milieu scolaire 2 c'est déjà le
cas en service civique dans le service
national universel on aura l'intégralité
du permis qui sera intégré trois pour
ceux qui sont en apprentissage
le permis est financée et il y a le
chèque de 500 euros qui fournit et 4 ce
qu'on veut faire c'est baisser le coût
d'acquisition du permis pour les jeunes
pour qu on puisse beaucoup plus
facilement avoir accès à celui ci alors
pour compléter le propos présidentiel
jusqu'à présent jusqu'à présent ça coûte
à peu près mille 800 euros un passé sans
permis donc c'est très cher l'airé c'est
de faire baisser sa avec un nouveau
système un peu une forme dubé risation
du permis de conduire
avec d'une part des plateformes en ligne
donc pas forcément des auto écoles de
proximité plateforme en ligne qui font
travailler des moniteurs indépendants
qui sont des auto entrepreneurs
et ça ça déplaît beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup aux sociétés classiques
écoutez le patron de l'union nationale
intersyndicale des enseignants de la
conduite
lui il aime pas les auto entrepreneurs
moi je demande l'égalité l'auto
entrepreneur c'est le le berre s'est
activée l'hôte entrepreneurs chez celui
qui va aider qui va apprendre la
conduite à l'élève celle hubert mais les
auto entrepreneurs ont le d'être salarié
chez vous voilà mais sur nous sur ce 1
10% il ya peut-être un peu de retraite
qui a peut-être un peu de maladies a
peut-être un peu de prestations sociales
si c'est ce modèle encore une fois moi
j'ai pas de d'états d'âme si c'est ce
modèle là que le gouvernement veut même
un étage au dessus je crois au palais il
faut le dire et ils vont nous le dire
rip alors vous pose la question sur
twitter selon vous la réforme du permis
de conduire est elle possible
et bien heureusement vous êtes
encourageants et positifs chers
internautes puisque vous êtes deux tiers
a considéré que oui
malgré le fait qu'on n'en n'est pas la
première tentative mais que jusqu'à
présent le la capacité de nuisance je
vais encore me faire des amis des
sociétés des auto écoles classiques
notamment en bloquant les routes fait
que les réformes ne sont pas allés très
loin
matthew pearce c'est très français cette
histoire on essaie de changer les trucs
et est aussitôt tout le monde râle
oui on a quelques professions
réglementées qui l'ont été pendant trop
longtemps et qui du coup ont sans doute
eu un tout petit peu de mal à évoluer et
au moment où effectivement elle se
trouve face au mur c'est un tout petit
peu compliqué donc jugé assez peu de
doute sur le fait que quand même on
arrive à faire évoluer un tout petit peu
le système dont tout le monde convient
dans tout le monde convient qu'il est un
qu'il est insatisfaisant on a tous été
au moins directement confronté au
business de nos écoles ça coûte très
cher
c'est très compliqué
discrète mais je ne sais pas c'est trois
fois à la base il allait rater très
soirée j'ai déjà payé 13 soit 1800 euros
non pas du tout mais je les sais que
c'est trop là est la confrérie des auto
écoles devraient surtout s'inquiéter en
fait de la voiture sans de la voiture
son conducteur en fait il me semble pour
eux en fait la vraie fin du business
c'est plutôt sa queue à un peu de
déréglementation qui permettra et
d'accélérer les processus probablement
d'améliorer un peu le service qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses négatives à dire sur
le beurre mais la profession des taxis
qui avait eu beaucoup de mal elle même a
évolué pendant vingt ou trente ans et
qui faisait qu'on était tous à paris
très insatisfaits du service de taxi a
été obligée d'augmenter son niveau de
qualité face à face à la concurrence des
rumeurs dont je ne fais pas l'apologie
du beurre mais parfois un tout petit peu
de déréglementation et un tout petit peu
de concurrence on est d'accord pour dire
que ça a ses vertus content parce que là
je sens que je vous irez concilier avec
agnès ferret les mulliez acquis celton
pris cette ode au libéralisme et à la
déréglementation réaliser ce pardon oui
bien sûr se souvient on peut pas être
contre une réforme c'est clair que c'est
trop cher quand vous dites 1800 euros
encore je pense que c'est gentil
je connais beaucoup du rac citoyenne
c'est ce que disent beaucoup de gens
autour de moi sans aller jusqu'à 2500
3000 euros parce que à chaque fois vous
êtes obligé de reprendre des leçons plus
cher à l'auto école
vous l'auto école qui décide de vous
présenter des sites que vous êtes prêt
ou pas prêt ou prêtes ou pas prête à
présenter et si vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas prêt troupes après il faut
passer cinq heures de plus
d'apprentissage en heures de conduite et
si vous décidez de vous présenter un peu
en candidat libre directement sans
passer par une auto-école ça prend
beaucoup plus de temps il faut attendre
des mois et des mois avant de passer
alors là on a un corps d'inspection des
inspecteurs du permis de conduire qui
ont aussi leur leur statut leur temps de
travail qui est assez un peu trop faible
par rapport à ce qu'on pourrait espérer
avec 35 jours de congés congé plus rtt
par an donc c'est vrai que là aussi il
ya un engorgement pour passer le permis
mais qui aussi lié au fait que là on a
quelque chose qui pose question alors
passé pendant le service civique c'est
pas une mauvaise idée passer le code à
l'école c'est pas une mauvaise idée le
passé en apprentissage
la voilà on peut pas on peut pas être
contre toutes ces propositions pourquoi
parce qu'on voit bien qu'on est dans un
goulot d'étranglement qui fait que la
une clientèle captive d'un côté et de
l'autre côté des inspecteurs qui font
passer au compte-goutte
les jeunes à l'examen mais moi le sujet
vous intéresse de toute évidence simple
sur internet puisque sur lefigaro.fr et
sur twitter vous réagissez babineau nous
dit macron à raison pour le coup le
permis coûte une fortune en france en
floride ces quelques centaines de
dollars
il ya une autre comparaison avec les
états unis le commentaire nous dit aux
usa tout le monde est auto école et il
n'y a pas plus de morts sur les routes
je sais pas comment ça fonctionne la
balance je veux pas commenter pour ça et
l on nous dit sur les 2000 euros de coût
moyen
combien en at il qui reviennent en
charge collectées par l'état à tous les
niveaux
votre point de vue sur ce sujet xavier
couture votre permis vous j'ai même
lutté pour le conserver en faisant des
opérations récupération en moins que je
recommande que je recommande pour la
meilleure connaissance de la sociologie
mais pour être ce qui me paraît clair
dans cette affaire c'est que on est un
peu comme dans les jeux les jouets
d'accord on a un président formidable
qui s'est fait élire on l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans une forme de
d'horizontalité d'utilisation des
réseaux d'utilisation de
désintermédiation des codes et des
fameux corps intermédiaires des
syndicats des partis voire de la presse
et puis qui gouverne de manière
extrêmement verticale
bon effectivement au premier la première
réforme fiscale malvenue on met 5 300
mille personnes dans les rues même s'ils
sont plus que 50 milles c'est cette
espèce de de télescopage d'une vision
horizontale de la gouvernance et d'une
pratique verticale se retrouvent dans
cette histoire d'auto-école franchement
sortir ça maintenant
alors qu'il ya déjà suffisamment de
monde note sur les ronds points
si on rajoute des auto-écoles sur les
ronds points ça va faire beaucoup de
monde je pense que ça mériterait et je
suis tout à fait favorable à la réforme
je pense que cette réforme est
nécessaire et que le mot épelé risation
il englobe une réalité qui est que il y
à un monde numérique de plateformes qui
envahi l'ensemble de l'économie et c'est
tant mieux
il faut que l'économie française s'y
adapte les professions réglementées sont
fidèlement les premières touchées
puisque l on pas réagir à cette cette
nouvelle pratique des plateformes
néanmoins je pense qu'un minimum de
préparation s'impose vous
imposerait où s'imposait et je suis pas
certain qu'elle ait été pratiqué cette
préparation du coup on a une réaction
épidermique
ça paraît stupide mais c'est
compréhensible de la part d'une
profession qui va qui se voit mourir du
jour au lendemain
même si encore une fois les taxis s'en
sont sortis mais je pense que reprise
auto école sera un peu plus difficile
alors passé la parole à corps une femme
enfin je précise que ya pas de d'agenda
gouvernementale immédiat sur ce sujet
mais il ya un parlementaire qui a remis
un rapport au premier ministre
préconisant cette réforme la semaine
dernière je alors et je vous donne en
plus le traçage sur le témoignage saddam
internautes qui s'appelle julien et qui
nous dit trois années de suite j'ai
travaillé tout l'été pour payer mon
permis
trois années de suite j'ai raté et
depuis je roule sans permis car l'une
valentin alors moi je trouve que
finalement quand on y réfléchit pour
être un peu cynique le timing il y pas
mal parce que vous allez mettre les
auto-écoles sur les ronds points
mais enfin sera léger léger ou cela non
mais en fait vous aurez léger les jaunes
qui auront tout intérêt à les faire
dégager avec des grands coups de pompes
dans le derrière
parce que c'est quoi l'intérêt de cette
réforme il est précisément pour ces jets
des jaunes qui ont besoin de leur
voiture et dans la jeunesse a beaucoup
de mal à payer son permis
or sans son permis cette jeunesse ne
peut pas quitter la maison de ses
parents
donc c'est vraiment cette réforme elle
est d'abord adressé les favorable à ce
sujet les jaunes
donc effectivement ça fait ça économise
des forces de police je dirais oui donc
alors en prêt sur le fond mais après
évidemment il va sans dire je suis
d'accord avec vous tous
cette ce privilège ces deux règles de
professions réglementées n'a absolument
pas lieu d'être ce permis coûte dix fois
trop cher
il coûte si cher parce que ces gens
bénéficie justement d'un acte d'une
profession réglementée qui limitent
l'accès à la profession qui interdit
l'accès à la profession a déjà tout un
chacun alors pour quelque chose qui est
vraiment très simple qui est conduire à
l'école on n'a pas nagé vous pourrez
tout à fait leur apprendre à conduire
donc c'est en fait évidemment que la
profession réagi mais j'espère qu'un
jour un gouvernement aura sa peau de
leurs principes de base
mieux régir ce qu'est la conduite sans
permis
la conduite sous stupéfiants la conduite
quand on est quand on est
en situation alcoolique et très dépassée
ce qui n'est pas le cas aux états unis
ont par ailleurs parce qu'on parlait on
parle et elle de présenter un accident
des scénic est très inférieur à celui de
la france parce qu'il ya un plus grand
respect de la législation en vigueur
pour simplement que les sanctions la
section est beaucoup plus d'ambition et
on ne parlera pas des 80 km on apprend
l'art une autre fois parce que c'est pas
le sujet d'aujourd'hui je laisse le
dernier mot si j'ai bien roulé doucement
et voilà deux derniers commentaires et
landon qui qui abondent dans le sens
daniel verdier molinié en disant c'est
l'auto école qui décide que vous êtes
prêts quand vous avez des pensées 2011
chez elle et christo dit et si les
écoles ne paient plus les impôts pour
payer pour baisser les prix des citoyens
ben oui sauf que chaque crise quand on
paie pas ses impôts en france
en général ça se passe mal parce que
s'il ya unis sera une administration qui
marche bien c'est bien celle qui est
chargé de les recouvrer nous passons à
un sujet plus macro économiques avec la
croissance en 2010 est la croissance
française était de 2 3% steptoe un bon
chiffre et tout le monde avait retrouvé
le moral on a eu les chiffres de l'année
dernière 2018 et là c'est moins brillant
1 5% c'est un net ralentissement et les
prévisions qui sont celles de la
commission pour 2019 sont pas très
bonnes puisqu'on est à un point que le
3%
alors on s'est posé une question toute
simple qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce
que c'est un ralentissement général ou
est ce que c'est la france qui fait pas
le boulot
et quand je dis la france c'est ton
particulier emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement pour que la croissance
revienne
je vous propose d'écouter pour commencer
le point de vue d'eric woerth député les
républicains c'est le président de la
commission des finances est alors lui il
est comme la france n'at il accuse un
gros coup de fatigue
la france elle est épuisée elle est
épuisée politiquement et elle est
épuisée budgétairement alors qu'elle n'a
pas commencé à faire le moindre effort
de réforme
donc c'est un sujet considérable on a
besoin de se réformer si on veut
continuer à distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat si on veut donner de l'avenir à
nos jeunes
si on veut incarner quelque chose encore
en europe et dans le monde ça c'est
maintenant qu'il faut le faire et la
france elle est épuisée avant même
d'avoir fait les efforts nécessaires
hannezo a témoigné qu'elle n'a pas à
votre avis de la responsabilité
française dans ce ralentissement dont il
faut dire qu'il est assez générale en
europe en général un en zone euro la
prévision maintenance et 1 3 pour
l'année prochaine c'est la france va
être dans la moyenne zone euro donc donc
c'est pas la faute de patron c'est
difficile de dire que tout en la matière
serait de la faute de macron de la
croissance supplémentaire qu'on pourrait
aller chercher un peu avec les dents
comme l'avait fait françois hollande en
2017 il faut se souvenir de ce qui s'est
passé au précédent quinquennat on était
un peu à la traîne pour aller chercher
pour aller récupérer la croissance qui
arrivait depuis l'extérieur de la france
si on peut dire ça comme ça et puis en
2017 on a eu deux ou trois points de
croissance vous l'avez rappelé mais sa
venue en grande partie du cic et du pack
de responsabilité pourquoi parce qu'en
donnant de l'oxygène avec de la baisse
des charges pour les entreprises
on leur avait permis d'embaucher est
d'ailleurs en 2017 on a beaucoup
embauché au niveau de l'emploi marchand
du secteur marchand des entreprises
françaises alors maintenant 2018 ça
s'est ralenti 2019
on voit que c'est encore pire est
vraisemblablement et finalement les
forts qu'on aurait dû faire pour aller
chercher une croissance supplémentaire
par rapport à la zone euro
on aurait dû le faire dès juillet 2017
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement a fait
une erreur et là on peut lui reprocher
de pas être aller grappiller ces 0 1 0 2
0 3 point de croissance qu'on aurait pu
aller chercher
il a fait une erreur en ne réformant pas
tout de suite le modèle français c'était
la transformation du modèle ce à quoi il
s'était engagé
eh bien ils ont décidé en juillet 2010
est de ne pas faire de loi de finances
rectificative et là tout vient de là
finalement pourquoi parce que on sait
que si on veut faire des transformations
de fond ça prend du temps c'est pas en
six mois que ça donne des résultats
c'est pas en six mois qu'on peut ensuite
véritablement aussi baissé par les taxes
sur la production des entreprises c'est
comme ça qu'on peut embaucher plus créer
des emplois marchands c'est en baissant
les taxes sur la production des
entreprises
mais on peut le faire que si on baisse
la dépense publique de l'autre côté ça à
bercy le savent très bien
le problème c'est qu'ils savent aussi
susurrer à l'oreille du gouvernement
surtout attention monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre est
attention si vous baissez trop les
dépenses vous allez casser la croissance
et c'est un cercle vicieux chaque fois
qu'on a plus de croissance on dit
attention va casser la croissance
et chaque fois qu'on a moins de
croissance on dit attention la
croissance est déjà faible on va quand
même pas faire les réformes
non et ça fait donc plusieurs mandats
qu'on attend alors comme d'habitude on
vous demande votre avis sur twitter
votre point de vue on vous a posé la
question alors comme toujours on vous la
peau de façon un peu caché puis et puis
vous répondu subtilement la question
c'est le gouvernement est-il l'unique
responsable de la croissance en berne en
france et vous êtes 54% à nous répondre
que non parce que la responsable la
responsabilité est partagée
mathieu ce qui est intéressant ce que
didier aniès vers des monnaies comme
toujours mais disent finalement la
croissance est aussi grâce à olemps
presque dire que c'était mieux sous
alors il a pris des mesures qui ont
permis d'aller chercher des points de
croissance supplémentaires on est tous
d'accord fils comme françois hollande et
brillant moi qui fais un modeste
collaborateurs à l'époque sous ce
quinquennat l'âge nous commentions tous
les trois mois en fait et les chiffres
de la croissance et les chiffres de
l'emploi qui ont dit qu il en chef que
la voie choisie à l'époque avec la
visite de travail exactement donc nous
commencions tous les trois mois et même
tous les mois en fait les chiffres de la
croissance et les chiffres du chômage et
tous les trois mois nous livrions un
argumentaire pour expliquer en quoi ces
chiffres étaient bon pas bon moins bon
super bon et c est en général on pouvait
préparer le communiqué de presse avant
même de connaître les chiffres puisque
on tentait d'expliquer on faisait mine d
expliquer quelque chose qu'on ne savait
absolument pas expliqué et du coup ces
commentaires sur la rythmique de la
croissance au mois ou même au trimestre
en fait sont pour partie un peu absurde
et en réalité ce qu'on observe c'est
qu'il n'y a aucun aucune coïncidence
entre les cycles de croissance et les
calendriers politiques ça c'est
incontestable ou alors c'est rarissime
c'est ponctuel mais encore une fois
c'est rarement une élection qui
permettent d'enclencher un cycle soit de
croissance soit de décroissance
il ya toujours un effet psychologique on
a cru que les milieux économiques
vive l élection d' emmanuel macron comme
la bonne nouvelle du siècle et que tout
ça allait enclencher une dynamique
positive bon on observe que ce n'est pas
exactement ça et que par ailleurs la
mémoire des acteurs économiques et est
très faible
dire que dans l'instant t des acteurs
peuvent être tout à fait enthousiaste
tout à fait optimiste et puis quelques
mois après deviennent eux mêmes aussi
pessimiste que tous les autres non si on
prend un tout petit peu de recul en fait
la france c'est vrai a toujours un
niveau de croissance qui est légèrement
inférieur à la moyenne de la zone euro
alors on peut dire comme certains que
c'est à cause de de tout tout ce qui
nous laisse tous qu'il est notre
économie et en particulier le niveau de
charge
d'autres disent qu'il s'agit d'
amortisseur qui permettent effectivement
alors quand on est en période de
croissance ont fait la plupart du temps
moins bien que les autres mais quand on
est en période de récession on fait
toujours un peu moins pire que les
autres quand il ya de la récession ce
fut le cas en 2009 par exemple tous les
pays européens ont dévissé de façon
brutale la france a beaucoup moins davis
et que les autres et ça c'est pas
quelque chose de récent dans les années
suite à la crise de 29 la france en fête
a continué à bien se porter pendant
quelques années mais elle a eu beaucoup
de mal ensuite à redémarrer aussi vite
que les autres et ça c'est une cdu c'est
une relative constance
donc voilà pourquoi on n'a pas de recul
et un petit peu de recul 1 5% de
croissance on commente le truc comme si
c'était la mauvaise nouvelle du siècle
en moyenne au 19e siècle
la croissance a été d'un pour cent dans
tous les pays développés au xxème siècle
elle a été de 2% en moyenne et en fait
l'économie française comme la plupart
des grandes économies européennes au
cours des dernières décennies est
toujours quelque part entre 1 et 2%
on fait semblant d'oublier que la
croissance exceptionnelle des trente
glorieuses en occident ou que la
croissance de certains pays ailleurs
aujourd'hui la chine et les autres sont
des taux de croissance normal n'ont en
fait jamais la croissance moyenne elle
est plutôt entre 1 et 2% et avec 1 5% de
croissance
aujourd'hui la france dont le pib de
2300 milliards ou quelque chose comme ça
je crois avec 1,5 pour cent de
croissance
elle prend 30 milliards à la louche de
de richesse supplémentaire
c'est assez rigolo sous jospin à
l'époque sous jospin on se gargarise et
des niveaux de croissance qui étaient
les nôtres à l'époque de jospin le pib
était de 1300 milliards donc à l'époque
jospin il fallait faire trois pour cent
du marais ans pour obtenir le même
surcroît de richesses qu'aujourd'hui car
il rata vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse en disant finalement c'est la
norme il faut s'y habituer c'est un
grand pas du tout d'accord avec cette
analyse mais moi je suis pas forcément
une
une sa chance mais j'ai des questions la
question c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
seul pays de la zone euro avant autant
de chômage ou un des grands pays de la
zone euro à avoir autant de chômage et
ça depuis très longtemps donc on a beau
avoir un pour cent de croissance on a
quand même énormément de chômage et dans
ce pays il n'y a plus de travail
l'espagne est un plus s'il peut répondre
par elle que je seulement lui vendant
mois parmi les pays
alors si on regarde vers le nord de
l'europe il ya vraiment des taux de
chômage qui sont très inférieurs aux
nôtres puisqu'on est à 3,7 en allemagne
comme moi on va aller vers le nord on va
être autour de 4 5% de chômage nous on
est toujours autour de neuf et on a
vraiment du mal à sortir de ses 9 % en
fin d'audition mire enfin tous les
catégories de chômeurs confondues vous
connaissez les chiffres par carte visa
est commentée tous les mois maintenant
c'est fini
rona on a 6 millions fin qu'un de
demandeurs d'emploi dans toutes
catégories avec moi parce que parce
qu'on a on n'a pas été capable de
recréer le lait le choc entrepreneurial
dont on a besoin c'est à dire en à pas
de géants occidentaux varial partout
dans les files d'europe
un exemple oui bel ami khaled et axa 0
les successions maintenant oui ça a été
décidé par la gauche mais pourquoi parce
qu'ils on y va c'est mieux de garder
chez nous les talents les entrepreneurs
les créateurs de richesse de permettre
justement aux très hauts patrimoines de
se transmettre
plutôt que de se faire racheter par des
fonds de pension étrangers par des
investisseurs chinois et ses 2 900
pragmatique on a peut-être de la
croissance mais on a beaucoup beaucoup
de chômage
on a sonné il ya une question qu'on pose
pas mais parce que c'est un débat
interne y met moment l'euro depuis
l'euro ça se passe pas très bien pour
nous depuis l'euro l'allemagne engrangé
des excédents qu'on a que nous on
décroche des déficits plus l'allemagne à
d'excédent l'union n'a déficit plus on
continue d'augmenter nos salaires parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on fait mais on
peut plus ajustés par l'inflation donc
nos entreprises donc plus de marocains
ne peuvent plus embaucher ces questions
là en fait pourquoi je dis que c'est la
faute des gouvernements parce qu'on ne
pose pas ces questions et parce que de
manière systématique on voit qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya un sommet franco allemand
sur l'allemagne depuis toujours et
depuis maastricht depuis mitterrand
c'est comme ça la france l'allemagne
les intérêts de l'allemagne elle
recherche les intérêts de l'allemagne et
la france recherchent les intérêts de
l'allemagne aussi en fait même des bains
on peut pas avoir l'air de rejeter vue
sur leur monnaie la situation actuelle
les allemands étaient aussi dans une
situation assez délicate ya quelqu'un
qui s'appelle schroeder avec un monsieur
qui s'appelle at il vous décidé de se
remonter les manches de faire de faire
le boulot que personne à l'enlever
salariés qui allait prêter d'argent et
il pourrait rembourser le salaire social
et sociaux des redditions de
l'exportation et la wii c'est
sociaux-démocrates ont permis notamment
de faire bien c'est la faute de la
défense sociale de d'avoir à la fois des
droits et des devoirs aujourd'hui à
beaucoup d'entreprises ont fui ce cliché
c'est bien lui fasse des économies mais
au bout d'un moment il ya la fin de
l'économie on aura fait tout et on a un
état au baiser impotent aujourd'hui qui
écoute beaucoup trop d'argent et qui
grèvent effectivement la clope et de la
compétitivité
une fois qu'on a ramené sa suis désolé
je finis une fois qu'on aura fait ça au
bout d'un moment il ya quand même une
dynamique qui ne repart pas et dont
auquel il faut s'intéresser et cette
dynamique elle est allée aussi sa
réponse dans l'union européenne et dans
l'euro il est anormal qu'on ne puisse
pas posé cette question et que même le
président nettement les exclus du grand
débat alors que tout part de là leur
part pas plus on l'a on a dit qu'on l'a
dégoûté d'avoir toutes les questions
alors là je vous interromps tout rousse
pour vous pour donner la parole à nos
internautes puisque le débat aussi fait
rage chez eux
et là on nous dit évidemment que le
gouvernement est responsable de ce
ralentissement de la croissance car son
dogmatisme libre échangiste se satisfait
de production hors de france
buteur pour mais non le libre échange
n'est pas le problème la france
n'exporte pas assez et nicole met tout
le monde d'accord en dix ans en plus de
ne plus produire
évidemment on importe trop en quelques
mots votre votre point de vue là-dessus
xavier majoré rebondir ce qu'a dit
mathieu ça m'intéressait de d'entendre
son raisonnement sur dans le fond il n'y
a pas de corrélation entre le cycle
politique et c'est bien la démonstration
que nous n'avons rien bouger depuis 40
ans ou 50 ans et que les politiques
publiques sont les mêmes et que les 57 %
de dépenses publiques qui sont un drame
dans ce pays ils n'essayaient pas de
revenir à moins de 50 57 % c'est
intenable et on le sait parce que ni la
chipie n'a pas été cité c'est la dette
nous sommes à plus de 100% du pib dans
plus de 2000
garden est très bien parfait les taux
d'intérêts aujourd'hui sont absolument
flat
on sait très bien que dans l'année il ya
un risque majeur de voir les taux
d'intérêt vont monter
pendant que l'allemagne a grosso modo 60
% du pib
c'est le volume de sa dette nous en
avons plus de 100 c'est un point majeur
et un point critique
on oublie la dette on se gave
d'amortisseur dont parlait mathieu ses
amortisseurs ils sont payés à coûts
d'emprunt et on va emprunter cette année
plus de 200 milliards sur le marché de
du financement international
tous les taux d'intérêt que peu
d'intérêt remontent d'un point et demi
ou deux points ce qui est envisageable
d'ici la fin de l'année et c'est un
drame pour la france donc oui il faut
faire des réformes
oui on peut paraître 57% oui on peut pas
rester à plus de 44 % de prélèvements
obligatoires
oui il faut faire enfin en france les
réformes c'est pas une question de
massacrer le pays et son système social
il s'agit de le rendre viable
aujourd'hui à horizon de 10 ans le
système d'amortisseur social dont tout
le monde se gargarise n'est plus à rien
il ya aussi une vision en fait très
hypocrite dans tout ça parce que se dire
qu'on va juste dire qu'on est à 3% -2 3%
ou à moins de 60% dette ça suffirait pas
il faut absolument au niveau des
critères européens donner un maximum de
prélèvements obligatoires est un maximum
de dépenses publiques ça on l'a jamais
fait on n'a jamais dit c'est 50% maximum
et ses 42 % maximum de tout près -
silicium après il nous reste quelques
minutes pour parler de rugby c'était
tellement bien mais oui je suis bien
d'accord mais non un mot il ya il ya une
autre singularité française qui en fait
- le chômage que notre capacité à nous
auto flageller
nous sommes sans doute pas meilleur que
les autres mais nous ne sommes pas non
plus plus mauvais que les autres
nous avons juste fait des choix un tout
petit peu différent mer ce showmatch
nord le chômage en europe le chômage le
chômage en france est exactement dans la
moyenne de la zone euro péenne euros on
est un avion on est on est toujours on
est toujours en europe
en un mot du jour c'est toujours un peu
avant cette moyenne vers certains pays
terminé match quasi aussi puissant que
nos économiques montrent un chômage très
supérieurs d'autres ont pas chômage
inférieur mais je le répète mais je
répète à chaque fois que il y a dans
l'économie française qu'est ce que le
singularité qui explique ce fait merci à
vous nous avons cette fois ci je vais
enfin la promenade et megrahi un choc de
voir faiblit c'est une cata crois aussi
vidé de sens personne ne m'écoute quoi
et cette fois ci je vais continuer à
parler juste comme ça je veux dire en
bord de plage le chômage ont amassé
plein dans la durée on peut le certifier
comment est-ce qu'il faut réformer
l'économie française pour qu'elle crée
plus d'emplois annoncées au rugbyman qui
vont finir je me remets qu'on reviendra
sur ce sujet oui je vous promets qu'il
est énorme je promets que vous avez des
choses passionnantes et tant qu'on va y
rester dessus l on pourrait le voir les
buts lombards avec du rugby mais si moi
je voudrais qu'on parle du rugby parce
que hier on est on a joué contre le
contre l'angleterre on s'est pris 36
points 44 à huit vous savez que s'était
pas vu depuis 1911 en 1911
l'angleterre a battu la france 37 à 0 1
foot du gic figurez vous alors la
question aller simple pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est si mauvais on donne la réponse
de jacques brunel qui le patron de
l'équipe le sélectionneur bas pour lui
on est mauvais parce qu'ils sont
meilleurs que nous aujourd'hui les
anglais étaient beaux était plus fort
que nous c'est savais que j'étais fort
nous l'ont montré qu'il était plus fort
que nous aujourd'hui n'a pas su répondre
alors à une situation qui s'est
reproduite toute une mi temps
xavier couture parmi vos nombreux états
de service vous avez été patron des
sports de tf1
si mes fiches sont à jour donc vous êtes
un spécialiste
à un moment il y avait la coupe du monde
de rugby le terrain alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé j'étais à l'époque rené la
lys bah voilà à l'époque on était bon et
puis aujourd'hui pourquoi mais je crois
qu'on a on a trois gros problème on a un
problème de formation
on a un problème de médiatisation on a
un problème de professionnalisation